Let's look at the answer
to our locality quiz.
We were asked, which of these
are not good examples of locality?
The statement that it
rained three times today so
it will likely rain today again
is a decent example of locality.
Usually if it rains often,
it's probably going to just
continue raining often for a while.
We ate dinner at 6 every day last week,
so
probably we will eat dinner
around 6 this week too.
This also tends to be true.
People tend to eat meals around
the same time for a while.
And finally,
it was New Year's Eye yesterday,
so it will be probably be
New Year's Eve today too.
This one is not a good
example of locality.
Why?
Well,
because some things
do not have locality.
For example,
it being New Year's Eve one day
usually means that the next day
it won't be New Year's Eve,
because New Year's Eve is one of those
things that do not have much locality.
If it was yesterday,
then we know it's not going to be today,
which is kind of opposite of what
the locality principle is about.
As we can see, some things do
have the locality property and
some things do not.